[Music]
elon musk playing with fire again
and this time it's not the type of fire
you put on a toy gun
whoa
whoa you know that reminded me of
muhammad ali he used to take some fire
from the match box and he used to go
ahead and put it by his hand like i was
trying to do right there muhammad ali
you know the the muslim american hero
and he would say man if i can if you
cannot take the fire in this life how
are you gonna end up taking the fire in
the next life and this used to help to
keep him in check okay guys you're
probably thinking how do we get to
talking about elon musk and the hellfire
well in this case it wasn't us that
brought up the hellfire it was elon musk
himself so it must be on his mind so
we'll just go ahead and continue the
conversation because it is indeed a very
important one so when you have love for
mankind and you want the best for
mankind and saving one person from the
hellfire is like you save all of mankind
so this is out of the love elon musk now
let's get into this twitter that was
sent to me that kicked all of this
off to talk about elon musk and the
hellfire started off with elon musk
saying if i die under mysterious
circumstances it's been nice knowing you
then a muslim by the name of muhammad
replied you won't die before your date
elon anyhow you are were a unique figure
in this world i'm only wondering one
thing as a genius haven't you found out
that there is a great creator of this
world yet
if you did make sure you confess this
before your last
heartbeat bless you and then elon musk
replies thank you for the blessing i'm
okay with going to hell he actually said
i'm okay i'm not saying i'm okay going
to hell if there is indeed if that is
indeed my destination since the vast
majority of all humans ever born will be
there now before we get into the topic
that elon musk brought up a hellfire
you're probably asking yourself does
elon musk even believe in a creator do
you even got
[Music]
now he did go to a christian in a jewish
school at a young age they say as a
child the boy elon musk attended an
anglican sunday school and learned at a
jewish preschool he did read the bible i
read like a whole bunch of religious
books including the bible and i'm like
there's a bunch of things now that i
didn't teach you in sunday school some
things that he read about jesus in the
bible he agreed with there's great
wisdom in what in in the teaching
teachings of of jesus
and i agree with those teachings some
things he didn't
you know god sure changes his mind
from the old testament in the new
testament i'm like whoa
that's pretty vengeful in the old
testament for example he talks about
jesus in the bible turning one of his
first miracles turning water into wine
like jesus was obviously very
pro-alcohol you know because one of his
miracles was turning water into white
yeah that was like they were having a
party they ran out of wine
and they're like let's keep this better
going
good stuff
who can solve
a white this
frigging store's closed
and jesus is like i got you
okay
order now i really believe if he would
have read the first miracle that jesus
did in the quran
which talks about jesus defending his
mother's honor
from the cradle as a baby versus keeping
the party going i like partying on
so you know accurate pro-playing with
alcohol eyes
so it seems like he's not denying god
but he's more borderline agnostic
and this is probably due to the
existential crisis he talks about having
at an early age when i was a kid i was
like i had this existential crisis and i
was trying to figure out what's the
meaning of life and i was like oh it all
means nothing and at one point in life
at a young age he was trying to figure
out what's this all about what's the
purpose of life and none of the books
that he read at the time had a good
answer to all this and he said he also
read many of the religious texts that
were out there now in my experience
interviewing over a thousand people on
the topic getting their stories
many of them did not come to reading the
quran knowing about islam until the very
end then after they looked at all the
different man-made religions and finally
came to the quran to islam only then did
they end up accepting islam as the one
truth submission to the creator not the
creation so if you ask me elon musk
probably knows very little to nothing
about islam and the little that he
probably knows is probably things that
he's read from
some of the haters out there who are
spreading the misinformation about islam
for example he says that science and
religion cannot coexist can science and
religion coexist
probably not
now if he learned some of the basics of
islam
if he looked into the quran now the
quran is not a book of science but a
book of signs and when islam was a
superpower when muslims ruled the world
just look at spain for example if he was
just to study take a little bit of time
to study islamic history and in this
topic that he's really into science he
would see that there was no conflict
between science and religion religion
and science god and science islam
actually led the way
you had many of the greatest scientists
and inventors
during the islamic civilization that
were prospering and growing unlike where
you had at a time and this is where all
this transpired where you had
contradictions and you had science
conflicting with the bible and then you
had people being persecuted who were
scientists and this is where the big
split happened and the separation
happened so he's probably equating that
most likely where
now because they couldn't go ahead and
make the two work we never had that
problem so with some basic knowledge of
islam he would see that there was no
conflict like there was between the
man-made religions and the divine
religion sent by the creator of the
heavens and earth islam submission to
the one and only one god the creator of
heavens and earth there wasn't this
conflict between science and the way of
life that god almighty has sent down now
there can be definitely things
that
discoveries that change because science
changes but islam is 100 percent on
point and we will not see no conflict
between these two i'd also like to ask
elon musk one question but at the same
time i'd like to give him an answer to
one of his questions elon musk asked the
question where does his super
consciousness come from
and it does beg the question if there is
some super consciousness of
consciousness where did the super
consciousness come from we'd say it
comes from the one and this one who
describes himself in the quran
now let's finish it off with this topic
that elon musk brought up the hellfire
now before we get into the hellfire you
have to understand that you have a
complete balance in islam in the quran
where god almighty talks about the
paradise
he is the most loving the most merciful
we come to know god almighty by his
attributes you see in the quran that
every chapter except for one begins with
in the name of god the most gracious the
most merciful we come to know from the
teachings of the last and final
messenger prophet muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him
that god almighty allah the creator of
heavens and earth is more merciful to
his servants than a mother is to her
child now even those that disbelieve in
him he's still feeding them giving them
food air and water would you if someone
who wasn't doing their job you know
about firing here elon musk comes with a
big penalty do we fire but with god
instead of firing it's the hellfire so
can you imagine if you created one of
your robots and that robot now was not
fulfilling its duty its obligations
serving you
what would you do to that robot would
you have a right to go ahead and do
whatever
you wanted to do with that robot if that
robot was not doing what it was designed
to do so god almighty created us he gave
us the answers to the test his life is a
test he set prophets and messengers and
they all brought the answers to the test
they all called us what we needed what
we needed to do in this life to be
successful i don't know how much more
fair you can you can get he told us to
worship one and only one god to be
morally upright to be a good human being
not according to our desires but
according to how at the time of jesus
how jesus according to revelation that
was sent through him same thing through
moses and abraham and the last the final
master prophet muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him so let's get back
to the topic of hellfire because all
these messengers they gave the glad
tidings of paradise
and they warned
people
and they try to keep people away from
the hell fire by calling people to
submit their will to the will of the one
and only created the heavens and earth
so it's your decision your choice what
do you want to do so we don't want to
have these bad expectations of god
almighty the creator of heavens and
earth we got to take responsibility for
our actions it takes us back to
gratitude to to being grateful i mean to
just to using the common sense and to
intuition that we have naturally we
incline to worship something to worship
the creator of the heavens and earth but
because you've been exposed to all these
man-made religions and worshiping a
human being sticks those and bones that
turns you away turns you off but now
when the truth comes to you and the pure
when you look into islam the pure
monotheism this pulls you towards the
worship one god when you get to know the
creator of heaven's earth by his
beautiful names and attributes that he's
the most kind the most just the most
loving
now you start to see the evidence and
proof
that prove that the quran is indeed from
the creator to heavens and earth and
then you have in there so many signs
and if you look at it you can go ahead
and put it to the test and then i'm
going to share
that question that i had with you
on it but first i want to go ahead and
just remind why would anybody want to be
in a place
you know a place where you can be in
paradise where you have everlasting
bliss and happiness and you never get
bored and uh you never end up feeling
sour anxiety or pain i mean this is
forever ever that's where you know just
a
small part of paradise is better than
everything in this world that it has to
offer why would you you know as a hadith
from the prophet muhammad peace and
blessing be upon him said that the
person imagine like an enoch musk or
someone who even more money who went
just imagine right now had everything
that your heart can desire that person
would deny the signs of god and believe
god's all just
he will show them at the end all the
proofs and evidences that came because
he's not going to punish someone unless
it's been
confirmed that this truth came to them
clearly so now what happens that person
will be dipped one time one time now
that person had everything in this life
everything that you can imagine ten
times more and then they'll be dipped
into the hellfire for a split second and
then they'll be said hey did you
experience anything good in this life
that person would say hell no no i
didn't that just for being dipped into
hellfire one time look at that but in
the contrary the person who had the most
difficult life
struggled and strived god almighty
purified him in this life and that
person believed believed in one god
lived a morally upright life but he made
mistakes the person she made mistakes
but they still held on to the true
teachings
of islam of submission to one god being
morally upright they held on to this and
then that person who had the hardest
life they'll be dipped into paradise
just for a split second and then they'll
be asked did you see any hardship in
this life they'll say no they'll say no
they'll quickly forget
and i mean we could witness that you
know just just how many times like all
those all the good times everything that
you went through now it's a it's it's
forgotten it's something of the past
but
though the sin still remains and then
the person who struggles to go ahead and
establish salah zakat to you know to
establish the things the injunctions
that god almighty for our good
that we need these things god doesn't
need the worship god doesn't need any of
these things it's to make us better
human beings it's it's a blueprint for
success in life
so those hardships will be gone but the
reward still remains the reward still
remains so let's go back to finish off
before i ask this question at the end
some key things about hellfire i don't
think there's anything out there you can
go ahead that gives more of a clear
vision of what hellfire is like along
with what paradise is like and i don't
think anybody would ever want to throw
themselves into the hellfire and take
that chance you know hellfire being 70
to 100 times hotter than this life than
this fire that we experience in this
life it's not even the orange yellow
it's black that's how hot it is
it's just pain after pain regret
depression anxiety it's like wanting to
die but you can't regret upon regret
never ending torment everything negative
and just imagine this kind this you
can't even compare it but this is just
so you can get some kind of idea imagine
would you want to put yourself into a
place where you heard this kind of
screaming
now let's finish it off there's a
question i want to ask you mr elon musk
chapter 4 56
this is the translation the original is
in the arabic
the meaning of which is it says
indeed those who disbelieve in our
verses
we will drive them into the fire every
time pay attention to this every time
their skins are roasted through we will
replace them with other skins so they
may taste the punishment indeed allah
god almighty is ever exalted in might
and wise so my question is how did
prophet muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him how did he know about the
pain receptors in the skin how did he
know this because imagine
you have
first degree burn second degree burn
third degree burn you don't feel any
pain anymore so someone will think like
i'll just burn for a little and then i
won't feel the pain so modern
science discovered this recently
but this is mentioned in the quran
so now ponder over there i leave you
with that
and there are other things we can talk
about the preservation of the quran we
can talk about developing the human
being and the embryo the dividing
between the two seas we get the
mountains actually there's pegs the
prophecies in the quran i'm telling you
and i'm not even talking about the
miracles that prophet muhammad did no no
i'm talking about the authenticity of
the quran and the believable message all
of these things are beyond one human or
group of humans being able to concoct
and put this thing together it's not
possible but i'm just leaving you with
this how did this man living in a desert
how did he come to know about this
latest scientific discovery of the pain
receptors where god almighty is saying
that
after because you brought up elon musk
the hell fire
so
the people who
choose to go in that direction and end
up there have no one but to blame but
themselves
and this is out of the love that's why
we're trying to
god will and save ourselves
and
you
save elon musk from the hellfire and our
brothers and sisters in humanity
and hopefully we can be together in
paradise that's where we want you to be
where we want to be together we want to
avoid this place where the skins will
burn up and then they'll be replaced
with fresh skins think about this verse
in the quran
and we end it right there i know it's a
sensitive subject for a lot of people a
lot of people ignore it they don't want
to talk about it just think about it if
you had someone who was just telling you
to hey look you can get a ticket there
the police are coming right you'd be
like thank you sir or you had something
about to fall down off a building and
the person pushed you out of the way or
someone ran into a
a burning house and got you and pulled
you out you'd be so thankful to the
person
so
before you get upset with the one who's
relaying this information to you
think about and ponder of the message
and the love that the person has who's
bringing this to you and then evaluate
it look at it put it to the test
and i'm not going to leave without
giving you a gift so you can yourself
because maybe some people have read the
quran but they've read so one that's a
bad translation
written by one of these uh islam haters
we're going to go ahead and give you a
gift you can go to thedeenshow.com and
get your free copy of the quran and i'll
leave you with this
something very simple ask for the
guidance guide me guide me guide me
that's the homework ask the creator of
the heavens and earth the one who
created everything you don't have to
give him a name say the one the most
merciful the most loving i say guide me
guide me guide me what's this all about
like you were asking elamas what's it
all about well ask the one who created
creation the one who created the
universe and everything in it to guide
you and then take it from there and then
hopefully accept this gift hook up with
us so we can help you along your journey
and inshallah god willing we can go
ahead and save ourselves and people like
elon musk from falling into a place that
nobody nobody in the right mind would
want to fall into and we'll see you next
time until then peace be with you
assalamu alaikum and if you liked this
episode of the dean show
like this video
share this video
far and wide and support us on our
patreon page so we can continue this
work
thank you for tuning in peace be with
you assalamu alaikum